anthony k will get to start trying to
get the blue jays off to the right note
here in this home stand
his first career start fourth appearance
versus the baltimore orioles his last
appearance ironically was saturday that
was excuse me in baltimore that was the
game where alec manual was thrown out of
the game all told anthony pitched three
in the third innings and that gave gave
up three hits and two earned runs
mancini bloops it and it'll drop in
there for a base hit
so trey mancini good career numbers
against the blue jays
loves to hit
there's another one keeps on going
sends it into right field for hernandez
mancini is going to stop at second base
two on one out and the batter will be
anthony santander
32 pitch
goes upstairs again and gets another
strikeout foul chip held down two by
rhys maguire the catcher two strikeouts
in the inning for cape
he goes back to the heater and strikes
out three
and for dean craiger
kramer the 12th start
the last two have been
a lot better he's been up and down twice
back-to-back walks to start the ball
game for kramer and that'll bring up the
very dangerous vladimir guerrero jr
three straight walks in a row to load
the bases to start to gain
tay oscar hernandez gets the hit with
the bases loaded and nobody out
there's a line drive in the left field
i'll score one for sure so the blue jays
are on the board for a second straight
game to ask her name this drives in the
first run of the ball game for the blue
jays
there's a contact and it's knocked down
his second throw to first in time
mcgrichick will be rewarded he shortened
up his swing picks up an rbi as bashing
comes in from third base fourth walk of
the inning and it reloads
the blue jay bases now you deal with
guerrielle
[Applause]
blue jays with those home runs there's
that hanging breaking ball inner half
boy that thing i'm sure his eyes lit up
when he saw that thing coming in there
his first career grand slam home run
that's the 23rd first pitch home run the
blue jays have hit this season
the 2-2
swing and a miss
it's a high fastball
that one is flared out to left-center
fields another soft hit
franco makes it into third base
and the orioles put runners at the
corners with one out
[Music]
and he gets him another high fastball
for a strikeout the bases are loaded two
down for trey mancini mancini's a good
rbi man here's a one-two pitch a
breaking ball and he went around
mancini's called for the swift
vladimir guerrero junior walked his
first time
swinging a drive a high fly by the left
and this ball is gone another
as the sole leader in the majors with 24
home runs he broke a tie with shohei
ohtani that was a classic vladimir
guerrero swing on a hanging pitch he has
quickly become a major league force
good swinging to miss a good breaking
ball there and kay now has seven
strikeouts hauls it in deepest part
you're gonna go back to grizzly time
this would be an easier playoff than
that at freddy galvez and i don't know
if the orioles are done in their half of
the third
here's mark is a simeon he's banning for
the third time in the third inning
breaking ball pulled fair down the left
field line
past franco
maguire's headed for a third and he's
been waved home here's the throw to the
plate from galves not in time
marcus with an rbi double that comes
with two outs now you have another guy
in scoring position with a guy that came
in 22 for 66 with runners in scoring
position
drive to right center and that ball is
going to split the gap and go all the
way to the fence
boba's shot has driven home marcus
cecimian back-to-back rbi doubles here
in the third with two outs
he looks in the change-up sum is last
time that he pitched
here's the curve ball comes to franco
all we got to do is talk about it
that was a good one
bouncing ball another play for franco
long throw in time and good six retire
good stretch at first by mount castle
mount castle is playing first base
tonight with trey mancini d.h
it's his 21st start over at first base
uh
he's played some left field he's played
some first base not sure where he's
going to end up in his career but it's
pretty good play right
there reaches in and looked like he left
the bag so wes says safe the 1-0 pitch
to biggio clubbed in the air center
field mullins racing back shy of the
warning track still backpedaling waits
for it he makes the catch
it's an out number two tag up at second
base great throw by mullins felika is
there to apply the tag and there's a
double play
swinging a miss good breaking ball down
and in another strikeout that's the
eighth strikeout for anthony k and it
ties his career high
another fastball flared into right field
oscar is going to get there and in this
mix of running kits just inside the foul
line
breaking ball tap back to the mound kane
has it
high throw no problem for joe panic the
inning is over lead off single is
stranded on base anthony k
through five innings has a nine nothing
lead
you know another guy as you mentioned
throws in the mid 90s with a big
overhand curve
first pitch fastball is hit into the
corner by severino and he will stand up
with a lead off double
mancini goes to right this ball is hit
hard but
the oscar runs it down in deep right
field right on the warning trap
maybe the first week of may and that was
the last time they've won a game on the
road
eric mullins gets jammed and that'll do
it the blue jays
shut off the orioles nine to nothing